did you have Matt Lewis on too already
Yes mat came on SE with us
yeah we were down there's there's quite
a story to that actually so Matt in his
wisdom day before we started filming
tweeted where he was and said Can is
anyone here know where I can watch the
leads United match oh my God and we and
so James and I just traveled from
England and to get to where we were was
the best part of over 30 hour 32 hours I
think it took just 36 hours from door to
door so you get you get into this hotel
lobby and there's a there's people there
like wanted to say hello and and
everything like that you know ni
yeah and then we get to watch le as well
who the hell wants to watch leads gets
gets yeah lose